the archbishop of san francisco has
informed nancy pelosi that her public
support for abortion constitutes a grave
and mortal sin and therefore she is not
to receive holy communion until she
repents confesses her sins and receives
absolution as the church has taught
consistently for 2000 years
but the self-styled devout catholic
nancy pelosi has rejected her bishop's
instruction just as she has rejected
other essential non-negotiable teachings
of the church to which she allegedly
belongs
pelosi's behavior has left many people
confused
which is why we are so fortunate to have
noted theologian and doctor of the
church whoopi goldberg to help clear up
the finer points of catholic theology
the abortion rights battle is starting
to blur the lines between church and
state the archbishop
of san francisco
calling for speaker nancy pelosi to be
denied receiving communion because of
her pro-choice stance he's one of the
priests who also called for president
biden to be denied sacrament this is not
your job dude
that is not you can't that is not up to
you to make that decision okay we have
to stop right there we will get to the
rest of what she said but we have to
stop there because
maybe whoopi is confused or i don't know
that is literally his job
that that that it is his job to make
that decision
that is what a bishop is that's what a
bishop does
whoopi goldberg might not know that
because she's not catholic no one is
really sure what whoopi goldberg
believes she has said that she feels
jewish
which would explain why she took a
jewish stage name but she her name is
not goldberg that's not the name she was
born with i think it's johnson uh she's
not jewish she doesn't practice judaism
nevertheless nevertheless
she she
a fake jew
is now going on to pontificate on
catholic eucharistic theology
what is the saying it's kind of amazing
uh
but
you know
what is the point of communion right
it's for uh sinners it's the for the for
sinners it's the reward of saints but
the bread of sinners how dare you
how dare you that is if pope francis
says that that's the issue now despite
whoopi's slam poetry and regardless of
the media's favorite one-liners from
pope francis that's not what the church
teaches
the church teaches and has always taught
for 2000 years that before receiving
holy communion catholics must confess
our mortal sins and we must repent and
then confess and then we can receive
communion sometimes we sin we don't make
it to confession on those sundays
faithful catholics choose not to receive
communion
because if we did we would in the words
of saint paul be eating our own
damnation now listen
you might not believe any of that
you might not believe all of it you
might not believe any of it
nancy pelosi might not believe all that
whoopi goldberg might not believe all of
that okay
no one is forcing these people to be
catholic
if they think that it's all a bunch of
baloney
why are all these libs so insistent that
pelosi be allowed to receive communion
in a state of unrepentant mortal sin if
they think that the church is wrong and
not just wrong but wrong on essential
teachings unchangeable teachings like
the teaching on abortion
then why do they care so much about the
catholic sacraments
the answer is clear
leftism is its own religion
abortion is its sacrament
and the libs want their blasphemy
blessed i don't want to bore you with
catholic theology i do have to correct
what whoopi goldberg is saying and i
know that it's probably the biggest news
story going on right now because you
finally got pushback against the speaker
of the house of representatives on this
essential question of abortion biggest
topic in the country right now but i
don't want to bore you with catholic
theology if you're not interested in it
you don't have any desire to become
catholic or practice the faith or
anything like that so then why do all of
these non-catholics take such a big
issue about it
why why does whoopi goldberg care
what is pelosi here what is joe
scarborough here joe scarborough very
much not a catholic just took to his
soapbox on msnbc to excoriate the
catholic church for
enforcing its 2000 year old teachings
this past weekend the san francisco
archdiocese has banned nancy pelosi who
we're having on the show tomorrow
speaker of the house from receiving
communion she's a staunch catholic uh
but because of her stance on abortion
they've banned her we'll be asking her
about that but this is this is where
we're going with all of this a lot of
opportunities for the democrats a lot of
challenges mika the catholic church
really the priests in the catholic
church really do have
a lot of room to stand to stand on their
high horse and be self-righteous
towards parishioners who have been
faithful parishioners for decades who
actually stayed with it through a a a
crisis where priests abused
thousands and thousands of children and
passed children around from one church
to another church from one diocese to
another diocese it went all the way up
to the top and they
are being self-righteous and telling
nancy pelosi that she can't take
communion they should thank god that
nancy pelosi has remained a catholic
through their torrent of of the most
grotesque sins imaginable
the catholic church should thank god
that nancy pelosi
an unrepentant
sinner who is flouting the essential
teachings of the church
is violating the instructions of her
bishop because
of the sex scandal in the church which
obviously was real but as studies have
shown
sex abuse is no more prevalent in the
catholic church than it is in any other
religion and it's certainly no more
prevalent than it is in the secular
leftist society it's actually much less
prevalent children are much much much
more likely to be sexually abused by
teachers in public school than they
would be by a catholic priest the
numbers are not even close and
furthermore
why does joe care why is joe getting so
worked up about this
why is he getting worked up about
a bishop of a church that he does not
believe in
enforcing the teachings of that church
the consistent 2000 year old teachings
on one of the
parishioners on one of the other
nominal members of the lay faithful
again the church that joe scarborough
does not belong to of the faith that he
does not believe in why is he why are
all the libs
so bizarrely obsessed with nancy pelosi
being able to
break the rules of the catholic church
and in such a way that will actually
harm her mortal soul if the catholic
religion is true
this is the question for me with pelosi
this to me
i think dispels all of the
media contrived pity party for nancy
pelosi here
why does pelosi
so badly want to receive the communion
in a state of unrepentant mortal sin
if
if
the catholic faith is true
then what the archbishop is doing is
helping nancy pelosi it is for her
protection
and we know nancy pelosi just went she
went to mass in d.c on sunday she
received
holy communion
in contravention of what the bishop of
san francisco her home her home parish
said
but if
if
if nancy pelosi does not believe in the
catholic faith if she thinks the
catholic church's teachings on abortion
which go back 2 000 years which remain
unchanged and according to the catechism
unchangeable you can never change it
then that means that nancy pelosi thinks
that the faith is false if nancy pelosi
thinks the faith is false why does she
care about receiving the sacraments she
doesn't believe in the sacraments then
so what's it to her
if on the other hand she believes that
the faith is true
then
surely she should follow the faith and
the faith is true on this unchangeable
essential teaching on abortion and she
should repent because she's imperiling
her soul she should do what the bishop
is telling her to do because the bishop
is trying to help her
maybe the catholic faith is true or
false you know i think it's true maybe
nancy pelosi doesn't
maybe you don't
whether it's true or not
whether nancy pelosi's faith is sincere
or insincere
the the craziest thing about this whole
controversy is that there is no
circumstance there is no combination of
any of those things in which pelosi's
actions are justified
it's so
so i i wondered to myself why why is she
so insistent why is joe scarborough why
are would we gold why are they so
outraged by this it is because you're
seeing a real conflict of religions here
christianity
versus leftism
and it's a battle between these two
faiths a battle between these two
churches
and and what the libs are demanding what
the pro-abortion people are demanding
is that the catholic faith surrender
and christianity broadly surrender
that's what they want
abortion is the sacrament as peter craft
says abortion even uses the same words
as the holy communion this is my body
except to a blasphemously opposite
meaning and what the libs are the reason
that all these non-catholic liberal
people heretics systematics apostates
all these people the reason they care so
much is that they
are insistent
that their blasphemous sacrament of
their unholy religion of leftism be
blessed by the
spiritual authority that's existed for
2000 years i'm glad you liked that clip
now hold up don't go you've got to smash
and ring and click and jab and poke and
anyway you got to subscribe and that way
you'll get the notifications also head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
audio podcast subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
leave a 10 star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you